except Magnus who played uh King D1 and  this pawn pawn sack well he didn't have  much choice anyway  so let's see  um now man will almost certainly take  with a queen on E5 I mean that's what  normal people do uh because you just get  the way out for your Bishop you just  exchange Queen you're always a bit  uh concerned about that King  especially after anyone if you take then  it's very very  weird position I mean there's some  compensation here  like this with Queens on yeah it's  actually like a very typical Scorch  compensation which I think might be  quite strong actually so I'm choosing  between either green the xc5 or or  actually your idea of playing g595 and  just opening the center like here fee A3  just go G5 yeah but then I didn't like  it anymore or something you know Bishop  seeks and just Castle along  and just try to